[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's brady quinn fox sports college and
nfl studio and game analyst and he has a
radio show on fox sports radio called
two pros and a cup of joe and it
precedes this program with levar
arrington and jonas knox you can catch
him weekdays six to nine a.m eastern and
uh that leads right into our show brady
joins us on the program brady good
morning what do you take away from uh
last night's browns win
i think two things uh one the the browns
have a roster and a football team that
is resilient i think can withstand some
injuries and still find a way of winning
football games especially when you see
the way case keenum played you know john
johnson at the running back spot uh but
that was something that looking into
this year coming into it i kind of felt
like the browns could withstand some of
those entries some of what happens
during the course of an nfl season and
for the broncos um i i think a couple
things offensively stood out you know
they just got to find a way of being
able to produce more points i know the
browns have a good defense especially
that front but the offensive line has
gotten exposed for the broncos the past
couple of weeks now and there's just
there's no big plays within that that
offense but they've got the
they've got the ability to make those
plays on the outside i just i don't know
if they need to take more chances or
what you want to attribute it to maybe
to play up teddy bridgewater but there's
some disconnect right now on offense for
the broncos that's a better football
team than i think their record shows
right now
and i know everybody's banged up the
browns are banged up the offensive line
you got your running backs you got your
wide receivers you got baker mayfield
there
and we add a 17th game i mean
it's a war of attrition here brady i i i
just i'm amazed at the players i know
money you know kind of trumps everything
but it's like yeah
bring in another game here it's hard
enough to get through 16. now you're
adding one more
and we're at week seven and you have all
of these injuries like
is this just an aberration or do you
think this is what you know we got to
get geared up for
no i think it's what we have to get
geared up for and the disappointing
thing is that the players didn't push
back and say we needed expanded roster
you know we need to have an even greater
roster in particular on game day we need
to have an extra bye week like all these
things that i think are important to
taking care of players bodies none of
that none of that got accomplished when
you signed on to a cba that was going to
you know potentially increase the 17
games and look eventually we'll get to
18 games i mean that's where this is
going it's all about money we know
that's the prerogative of the nfl owners
at some point
if the nfl pa is is really being honest
with themselves they need to start
taking how you know how many games these
players can actually take seriously and
realize that it is a brutal physical
sport and you have to do something to
counteract the toll that's taken on
these players bodies whether it's again
additional buy uh expanding the roster
so you've got you know the ability to
have more guys on there more guys
practicing throughout the course of the
week too uh just additional bodies to
help with that give guys rest i mean
there's a myriad of ways i think you can
circumvent some of that but uh it
doesn't seem like the nflpa understands
those leverage points to kind of flex
against the owners in those negotiations
baker mayfield wants to come back
but he's got i mean it's his
non-throwing shoulder but
it that's part of your dna is the
quarterback like you have to get back
there but is that a good thing for the
browns is that a good thing for baker
that he's trying to you know come back
maybe sooner than he needs to
well he is kind of i don't want to say
in a contract here but i think he'd like
to get that next contract so clearly
there's some incentive to come back
there i think any time you're a
quarterback and you're on the sideline
and you're watching a guy go in there
and be able to operate the way case
kingdom did last night i don't know how
much longer you want that to go on you
know you don't want that thought to
creep in back of anyone else's mind
where you say
well this guy puts together a string of
three or four really good games i'm not
saying case keem's gonna be the guy but
i mean let's just let's just say after
the season
there's a chance maybe russell wilson's
available i mean we're still hearing
trade rumors for deshaun watson i don't
know if any of that's going to come
through or not now
if it doesn't maybe after the season he
becomes available depending on how the
legal situation squares itself out
um
aaron rodgers i mean there's speculation
this might be his last year in green bay
there's a number of quarterbacks so i
think would look at that roster in
cleveland and go yes sign me up for that
so um i i think you got to be careful if
you can come back and play and it's not
going to diminish your ability to go in
and play effectively yeah you probably
need to be back in there and be a part
of your team and try to make that
playoff run but why can't the browns go
now i i don't want to give baker a
long-term contract you know and i'd
still like to see what happens the rest
of the year before i do that but even
then
i can't give him 40 million dollars
like what if i just said five years 150
because how much that is guaranteed
uh
let's
make uh three quarters of it guaranteed
how's that
okay i'm trying to do the quick math my
head here it's kind of early in the
morning out here on the west coast stand
so i'm trying to put this all together
no i i think i think it all depends on
the structure of that contract what it
looks like and then what he feels
comfortable with at this point yeah but
what's his marketplace though brady if
like what's what's he gonna do hey we're
gonna give you this who's gonna give him
top end money
well i think a quarterback needy team if
he was able to hit free agency i mean
that's the reality of it so you know
what that contract is gonna look like we
talked about this before his fifth year
option next year and then two additional
years of the franchise tag that should
be the base uh really the floor of those
negotiations of what he would sign an
extension for at least what the first
three years would look like so
um you know calculating some of those
numbers into it if they offered him
anything less than that i'd say no
because i'd be willing to go through the
risk at least and that's just me maybe
he wouldn't maybe he wants the financial
security of having that love of some
some of money right now sure but they've
already picked up its fifth year option
and if they pick up the subsequent you
know franchise tags for you know years
one and two in that each year's
guaranteed so i just it all depends on
what he's willing to do how how long
he's going to push this and what he
thinks he's worth in his mind you and i
might have an idea of what he thinks
he's worth but i can promise you this
every single quarterback in the nfl
thinks to the best and they think they
should be paid the most that's just how
we're wired that's how we think it might
be crazy to everyone else out there but
that's what we think in our minds case
keenum probably even thinks that he's
probably thinking like give me another
game let me show you what i'm all about
and i don't know if it's a big drop off
with case keenum
i i mean he knows kevin stefanski from
minnesota he he's he's played in you
know a couple of big playoff games
it's just the difference is star power
here
in my opinion
it's star power i think there's some
other intangibles too i think baker has
a stronger arm i think baker's best
football is his ceiling's higher than
probably what cases is but to your point
you know i don't i don't know that the
floor is is really that much different
from those two and i think case is very
serviceable i mean we've seen him be
able to make a playoff run in the past
so especially with the good teams
surrounded around him which they've got
right now in cleveland so that's a fair
assessment but you know ultimately it
comes down to the browns have to make a
decision on do they feel like baker
mayfield is good enough to win them a
super bowl and if they're comfortable
with being able to check that box and
say that's the case then the contracts
the contract because the reality is of
these contracts
you know you're gonna end up redoing it
especially it's a five-year deal three
years into it probably if things are
going how you want them to go right if
you have the same head coach the same
general manager and you're winning
football games you're already gonna have
to renegotiate that contract either to
create cap space for another player or
because you don't want him to get any
closer to free agency and the more
economical way of doing that is to be
able to you know negotiate or
renegotiate that extension earlier in
that contract rather as opposed to
waiting until it gets closer to free
agency so that's that's all if
everything goes well if it doesn't go
well yeah you've got a new head coach
new general manager you know he might be
playing out that contract or maybe being
traded on that contract there's all
those what-ifs is brady quinn fox sports
college and nfl studio and game analyst
is odell beckham a top 10 wide receiver
i would say talent-wise yes i don't
think the production has equated to that
lovely and a lot of that you know has to
do with injuries and the system that
that he's in i mean is this the best
system for otto beckham to be in
probably not i mean they're they're
really to be honest a run first team and
they base everything off of that
so
um i i still think he's a top 10 talent
i really do um i think the narrative
that
if he's not out there you know it's it's
easier on baker mayfield or their
offense is better i'm like where's the
logic there i mean do you think any
defense is is going up against the
browns saying uh we hope we hope bildo
beckham's you know in the game because
that makes them a less potent offense i
mean he's he's obviously a mismatch for
a lot of defensive backs he's obviously
got the big play ability and the ability
to hurt you down the field so no defense
is going to walk into a game uh with
otto beckham and being like oh thank god
he's on the field right we don't have to
worry about that guy right he's
he's clearly he's clearly one of the
more talented wide receivers
they have not been able to find that
chemistry and they have not been able to
kind of get him rolling because i think
he is one of those players where once
you get him rolling uh he he becomes
that you know
unstoppable force if you will
i don't think he can catch with two
hands
like it's crazy there's i don't know why
i swear to you some of the best best
hands and the best guys i played with
they can always make the ridiculous
catch or one-handed catch but the drops
are always the ones that are like the
easiest ones yeah and i just think
they're so confident their ability to
make that catch that they start to take
their eye off the ball they start to
move a little bit off field
you know it's like as a quarterback you
know sometimes the hardest ones to hit
are the ones wide open you know it's
easier when you have a tight window
because you understand exactly where you
need to pinpoint that ball when you got
a guy who's running with 10 yards of
separation you just want to make sure
you're not the guy missing that throw
you got to make sure you give it a
little bit of a room for air
usc notre dame this weekend
your favorite usc notre dame memory
memory is what
i don't have many i mean
yeah you know back then back then they
were rolling you know it's been
seventeen hundred and eighty
or seventeen hundred ninety days now i
think since uscb notre dame
um you know notre dame's won the last
three or i think six of the last eight
and uh you know so it's been a different
a different deal i mean that's how
rivalries are you know a lot of times
you get the ebbs and flows of rivalries
between
two teams and that was usc's heyday um
and then after pete left
he obviously uh i think the s and usc
standing for sanctions at that point and
they haven't really been able to recover
since
um but uh no i mean it was probably the
o5 game i mean i you know we called a
play
um it was it was a quarterback draw and
charlie told me earlier in that week
he's like you're we're gonna i'm gonna
call this play and you're gonna run in
for a touchdown and we're gonna win the
game this is charlie white and
charlie weiss our head coach at the time
and you know he was
the green jerseys everything building up
to that game made it really special our
pep rally which traditionally was in the
joy center back then they held in the
stadium because there were so many
people are in town for it i think we had
50 000 or something like that for a pep
rally you know
um yeah i couldn't exist during during
the cold coven deal but
it was you know that play i mean
reaching across the goal line putting us
you know ahead at that moment uh it was
i mean just everything coming to
fruition but at the same time looking at
the scoreboard going we left them too
much time you know that's honestly how i
felt my heart is knowing how good matt
and reggie were in that entire offense
like i knew we left too much time
on the on the board
and then when you realized that you had
the uh bush push
um
did you have a good angle when you're
watching that yeah i saw it i mean i
knew it was illegal you know but
well what happens between the lines
during the game no one's going to come
back and say they saw anything different
i mean it's a legal play now
but back then it was illegal and the
officiating was honestly awful down the
stretch i mean the spot for that play in
particular was a terrible spot but you
know it is what it is uh i would have
hoped my running back would have done
the same thing if it was me going in for
a quarterback sneak um and that's what
you do to try to win the game i honestly
blame
i blamed our pa speaker in the stadium
because everyone rushed the field and
i'm thinking like look
if the officials feel too much pressure
maybe they just call it game over and
everyone runs off the field and
everyone's still celebrating but
they uh they made sure everyone cleared
the field and they got the chance to
kind of collect themselves and have that
one final play so
um it was it was an incredible
atmosphere it was obviously
um a pretty hard loss to take but it was
a very fun journey that entire week was
very memorable okay but you're gonna see
liner and reggie bush on saturday
how long does it take for
that conversation to come up
well here's what you have to understand
at fox there's a lot of usc alum who
then transition over to work for fox
so i'm constantly reminded of it it's
not like we've got a bunch of notre dame
alums who are like trying to figure out
a way of not putting it in there like
they actually referenced it last week i
mean we weren't even playing last week
both teams were all buys but they still
they've still referenced it so i can't i
can't get away from it i just keep
trying to remind them like you know
again you know you guys have you guys
put aunt becky in a jail cell or
whatever with some of the stuff going on
with
i was like maybe southern couch would
focus on that but not so much replaying
a highlight from 15 years ago
you did a full house reference for these
guys
i love dan becky i'm just saying
it seems like they got a lot of people
paying to find their way
you know my son and and one of my
daughters went to usc and how they went
there i have no idea on their own merits
by the way you have something to tell me
no something to tell me no you know but
the funny thing is is my daughter called
me when this whole thing broke and she
said
she said dad
swear to me that you did not pay for me
to get in usc i go what are you talking
about
i i said i'm paying tuition she goes but
you didn't you didn't bribe anybody did
you down i go no
no
i s and then i say to my son i said i
didn't hear from you goes no i knew you
didn't have to prime for me to get into
usc
that's weird because i've been on their
campus i remember seeing this patrick
building yeah i was wondering i was like
i wonder who donated that
it's a beautiful building by the way
yes it
is yeah it was just a donation it was a
gift brady yeah and just a gift
uh good luck this weekend you know fight
the good fight
okay i will yeah
don't fight on fight the good fight
we're going to watch the game again and
then for some reason people seem to
think like it's going to end differently
i'm like no it's
the same way every time
thank you brady
thank you that's uh brady quinn uh fox
sports and uh he co-hosts two pros and a
cup of joe that's the show that precedes
ours on fox sports radio